we're on problem 245 if X plus y is
equal to a X plus y is equal to a and X
minus y is equal to B X minus y is equal
to B then what is they want to know what
2x y is equal to now let's solve for our
x and y in terms of a and B and then
just figure out what this equals to so
we have two two equations with two
unknowns let's just add them together to
solve for X we get X plus X is 2x the
Y's cancel out is equal to a plus B
where X is equal to a plus B over 2 now
if we had if we had X plus y is equal to
a I just rewrote this and now if we
multiply both sides of this by negative
1 so we get minus X plus y is equal to
minus B and now add these two equations
so I'm essentially subtracting this
equation from that one I get that
cancels out so I get 2y is equal to a
minus B or Y is equal to a minus B over
2 and now we can figure out what 2x y is
equal to 2x y is equal to 2 times a plus
B over 2 times a minus B over 2 this two
will cancel out with one of these twos
and we're left with and what's a plus B
times a minus B it's a squared minus B
squared over two which is choice a
choice a problem 246 let me do it in
magenta 246 a rectangular circuit board
is to have width w inches let me draw it
so let's say it has width W inches
perimeter of P inches okay so let me
just put that at the side right here
perimeter of P inches an area of K
square inches which of the following
equations must be true and so they want
us to relate the this width to the area
to the perimeter let me introduce
another variable let's call this and
let's call this right here let's call
this the height of the circuit board so
now we can do some interesting things if
that's the height then that's also the
height if that's the width and this is
also the width so let's see what the
perimeter would be well would be two
times the width two times the width plus
two times the height plus two times the
height is equal to the perimeter and
then we could also say what times height
is equal to area but if we can solve for
height in terms of the perimeter and the
width then we could use that to get an
expression that doesn't involve this
variable so let's let's do that so if
you divide both sides of this by 2 you
get width plus height is equal to
perimeter over 2 and then you get height
is equal to perimeter over 2 minus width
so this is equal to perimeter over 2
minus with and so the area K will be
equal to the width times the height and
instead of writing an H there let's
write what we just figured out P over 2
minus W all right and then that is equal
to so that is equal to let's see P W
over 2 minus W squared let's see when I
look at the solution they have a they
don't have any fractions in it so let's
multiply both sides equation by 2 we
could ignore this K is equal to PW over
2 minus W squared multiply both sides by
2 you get 2 K is equal to P W minus W
squared let's add W squared to both
sides you get W squared plus 2k is equal
to PW let's subtract because all of the
choices have them setting equal to 0 so
then we could subtract PW from both
sides and you get you get oh wait I made
a mistake if we multiply both sides of
this by 2 2 times K is 2 K 2 times P W
over 2 is PW 2 times minus double square
is minus 2w squared so in this step we
have to add 2w squared to both sides
sorry about that so we have 2 W squared
Plus 2k is equal to PW subtract PW from
both sides you get 2w squared minus PW
plus 2 K is equal to 0 and that is
choice E right 2 double squared minus PW
plus 2 K that is choice E next question
problem 247 247 an arithmetic sequence
is a sequence in which each term after
the first is equal to the sum of the
preceding term and a constant if the
list of letters shown above is an
arithmetic sequence so they wrote P r s
t u so all they're saying is that to go
from P the difference between P and R is
going to be some number and as the
district we an R and s is going to be
that same number the difference between
s and T is going to be that same number
so you know an example of an arithmetic
sequence this could be 1 2 3 4 5 because
every number is 1 more than the one
before it
so anyway they say which of the
following must also be an arithmetic
sequence so choice 1 they write to P - P
- R - s - t - u well let's just use our
example if this was P rst and you what
is 2 times all of that well then it'll
be 2 4 no no sorry it would be yeah 2 4
6 8 10 so now instead of incrementing by
1 every time we're in crediting by 2
every time but it's still an arithmetic
sequence because the difference between
each number the number before it is a
constant it's always equal to 2 so
choice number one is definitely an
arithmetic sequence
choice 2 choice - no if and if you say
well that works for that example how do
I know it work for all examples so the
other way to think about is whatever the
difference is between p and r now we're
gonna have twice the difference between
two p + 2 r and twice the end whatever
and it was the same difference between r
and s and i gonna have twice that
distance between 2 r + 2 s so here in
our particular example went from 1 to 2
but it could have been something else
okay statement 2 says P minus 3 R minus
3 so they're just shifting everything I
don't even have to write them all in all
the way to u minus 3 so they just took
all everything in this sequence and made
them three less but if if P minus if or
if R minus P is equal to some number R
minus 3 minus P minus 3 is going to be
the exact same thing I can even prove
that to you right R minus P sorry R
minus 3 minus P minus 3 that's equal to
R minus 3 minus P plus 3 and so these
cancel out so the difference between
this and this ends up to be R minus P
the difference in that and that and that
should make sense intuitively that we're
just shifting we're just shifting all
the numbers down by 3 so that shouldn't
change the difference between the
numbers so 2 is still an arithmetic
sequence 3 statement 3 P squared R
squared so we're just squaring all the
numbers T squared and u squared so let's
just use our particular example if P was
1 that P squared is 1 hour 2 squared is
4 s squared is 9 right 3 squared is 9 4
squared is 16 now what's the difference
between the numbers difference here is 3
difference here is 5 difference here is
7 and this is interesting in of itself
but the that well I mean well first of
all let's just answer our question the
difference is now not constant we have a
different difference between each
successive number right at the beginning
you know here's to the difference is to
every time here's 3 then it changes to 5
then it changes to 7 so 3 is not an
arithmetic sequence so the answer is d 1
& 2 but I will I will just you know this
is something interesting and if you've
never experimented with it this is
something to look at it I've always been
fascinated by the distance between the
perfect squares increases by increasing
odd numbers which is just something to
think about anyway next problem
next problem actually I have two
problems left out of all of the problem
solving problems so I'll save instead of
just doing one problem and going
overtime let me do two
of them in the next video see you soon